but if that happens black will go for a  checkmating attack and succeed  yeah scary  for wesley so right now i was also going  to say he doesn't even need a  checkmating attack a draw is sufficient  so if he wants to  true he can just accept the repetition  of moves although checkmating is much  better than drawing yeah checkmating is  going to happen look at the white king  it's just too weak it's  defenseless  and  wesley so leaning back is he getting  ready to resign is he gonna  i mean there's nothing else to do here  for wesley  it's that difficult his position levon  aronian he weathered the storm defended  calmly and  now he's on the attacking side okay  we're going to see queen takes bishop  and will we see a draw from levon  iranian or will he go for the checkmate  okay he repeats the position and there  we go it is a draw levon takes the draw  and seals today's match  congratulations to magnus carlsen he is  the winner of the mouthwater champions  chess tour 2021